cdc director dr rochelle walinski doctor
thanks so much for making time for us
today
good evening brett thanks for having me
you've heard those two reports and
obviously there's concern about the
messaging and what's coming out i want
to put up a couple of full screens first
and they were referenced in those two
reports
first is breakthrough numbers fully
vaccinated americans it's a real
uh credit that 164 million plus
have been vaccinated of those we're told
from your organization that
hospitalizations are at 6 200. that's
.0038 percent of fully vaccinated
and of those deaths are at 1263.007
fully vaccinated so break down these
numbers
and the concern about the vaccinated and
the changes that you're making yeah
thank you for raising this so i'm 164
million people fully vaccinated
and that i think is a true success and
we still have a lot more work to
do i want to be very cautious about the
interpretation that you just made with
those 6200 cases
the cdc monitors breakthrough infections
in numerous ways and one is through
passive reporting so the report you have
up there with those 6200 cases is
passive reporting that is when
we rely on hospital systems to report
breakthrough infections as they come in
we can learn a lot about them but what
we recognize is that is woeful
under reporting we actually don't get
all the reports that we need
and so what we do is we bolster that
with cohort studies
these are tens of thousands of people
that we follow across the country
people like essential workers like
health care workers long-term care
facility members and residents
and so we follow those to assess the
real epidemiologic way to do
breakthrough infection analysis that the
the
passive reporting is not the best way to
do it understood that so and i saw
some of the stuff you put out about
massachusetts and what you looked at in
that one community
but in the internal slides from the cdc
that that got to the washington post
it appears that some of your decision
was partly based on a non-peer-reviewed
study
from india that looked at vaccines not
not approved in the u.s so i guess the
question is why are you using foreign
data
of non-us vaccines as at least a part of
a basis
for your decisions here yeah let me be
very clear that was an internal briefing
to me to give the comprehensive view of
what was out there in the literature
the india data were not at all used to
make this assessment
i'd seen last friday the data from
massachusetts that were published today
and i certainly didn't want to use one
single site in order to
to make that an out to make that
assessment and to to change these
guidances
so what we did is we looked at other
sites that were
that were conducting outbreak analyses
and discussed with
some international colleagues who are
ahead of us on the delta variant
to see what we can glean and what became
very clear is that the data that we saw
in massachusetts
were corroborated in numerous other
places and that's when we knew we had to
take action
but to be very clear that internal
briefing was
not um that what the data that we used
to make the decision in fact
the decision was made after that
briefing all right but you're leading
with the information that the vaccines
work
that they're effective that they prevent
for the large part hospitalizations and
deaths
absolutely and that remains fortunately
to be true with the delta variant so for
the masks
to be added to that are the vaccinated
people wearing the masks
to protect the unvaccinated people or
are they protecting the vaccinated
people
the vaccinated people so if you are
vaccinated when you are vaccinated
you are protected from severe disease
and death and when we remove the masks
on
in may for the vaccinated people the
alpha variant was the predominant
variant and we had data to suggest at
the time that if you were infected as a
breakthrough case
that you couldn't give disease you
couldn't give alpha disease to someone
else
fast forward now the end of july the
predominant strain here is delta
and so what we were the data that we saw
was actually unlike
alpha delta allows you to transmit to
somebody else so
the masks are really being put on for
vaccinated people
in areas of high density disease such
that
if they were to get infected that they
knew that they might bring it to
somebody who is immunocompromised
somebody who was not yet
vaccinated so it was really to prevent
transmission right
dr wolinski you can imagine people you
know confused by the messaging from the
beginning to now and we understand what
you're saying is that the
variant caused evolution of how it
reacted
however there is a feeling that the goal
posts moved here
a bit here is dominick with the question
about that
good evening brett and dr worlenski this
is dominic marcy from vienna virginia
with a couple questions
if it's considered rare to get covet 19
if you're fully vaccinated with the
delta variant
when will we ever get back to normal
when masks are not required
and my second question is if other
variants come along
at what percentage of cases of
hospitalizations
do you not recommend wearing masks thank
you
let me just put a finer point on it you
know we started this whole thing with
trying to stop the spread and we were
going to
flatten the curve to prevent hospitals
from being
overrun but now it does seem
dr wolenski to dominic's point that we
are trying to kill this virus
entirely and can you just answer his
percentage point question
um yeah thank you dominic thank you for
that question so i think it's really
important to recognize that
as we think about the absolute number of
people who are getting infected that is
related to the number of people who have
disease
the number of people who are vaccinated
and how well those vaccines work so it
is actually quantitatively possible
to have 95 percent protection
from hospitalizations and still have a
lot of breakthrough infections if most
of your population
is vaccinated but is there a normalcy i
mean is the next variant just around the
corner
uh and is that something you know that
we're always going to be
on this stop and start with putting
masks on or not
so i i want to just articulate that this
was not
news that i expected the american people
to
welcome this weighed heavily on me
to be to have to do this but i will also
say that this virus has been humbling
i was taking care of patients a year ago
i
joined the cdc six months ago and the
science continues to change and while
that is neither simple
nor easy to convey it's my
responsibility to keep the american
people safe
and as that science evolves i evolve
with our with the cdc the guidance what
i will say is i continue to be humbled
by this virus
i have no interest in continuing mass
guidance and the best way to stop
a new variant from spreading is to have
less
virus out there and the best way to do
that is to get people vaccinated and to
mask up until they are dr wolinski you
said the other day that
we're just two or three mutations away
from a variant
that can't be defeated by our vaccines
there were some former health officials
top
health officials who found that
troubling and thought it was a little
bit fear-mongering because they believe
that the the uh vaccine uh
that we have currently the mrna
can be adjusted to deal with whatever
variant comes down the line and can be
uh fixed within you know a matter of
time in
a short matter of time is that factual
um i think both are potentially true um
i said i believe a few mutations away
you know the virus is smart
the virus is out to make sure that it
can survive and it is an opportunist it
will go where we are not vaccinated
the more the virus is mutating the more
it has an opportunity to mutate away
from
our vaccines and to be able to evade
them
that i think is true and that's the
general concern of science we're not
there yet and we're very lucky to not be
there yet but we have a lot of irish
circulating here
it is very true and i think it's a
scientific
um win that we have mrna vaccines that
can be adapted
um for new viral variants new mutations
and that's that's amazing however um
that will take some time
and so what we'd really like to do is
not have to be in that place
last question quickly we're going to
take a break in a second but but
speaking of time
when is the fda going to authorize the
full
approval of vaccines that have been on
emergency authorization
so far the president the other day said
it's the fall but the fda has put out
that it might be january 2022
why is it taking so long um you know i
don't know the fda's timeline or plans i
will leave that squarely with the fda
but what i do know
is that the due diligence and the
science and the review and the
epidemiologic data
need to be done and the fda is working
hard to do so
are you for mandating a vaccine
on a federal level um
you know that's something that i think
the administration is looking into
it's something that i think we're we're
looking to see approval of from the
vaccine
um overall i think in general i am all
for
more vaccination but uh you know i i
have nothing further to say on that
except that we're looking into those
policies and and
quite honestly as people are doing that
locally um those are those are
individual local decisions as well
right but you're in the medical field
and you can
hear the pushback from people who say i
need to determine what is put inside my
body
with my doctor so you get that pushback
i completely understand the pushback and
i also
understand that this is not unlike other
things that are mandated other vaccines
that are mandated for school going
children
for healthcare personnel i mandate it
every year as i work in the hospital to
get a flu vaccine
so um there's i understand both
perspectives in that story it's it's
i understand but why is it then dr
wolinski that
such a high percentage of medical
personnel are not taking
the vaccine um yeah
you know again this is a very
heterogeneous country
and so um if you look at certain parts
of the country there are high levels of
vaccination
and if you look at other levels of the
other parts of the country there are
lower levels of the vaccination
um i think it's really important to
understand that everyone has a different
reason for either wanting the vaccine
or not wanting the vaccine so this is
not about
you know why is this demographic not
getting it some people haven't had
access some people haven't had time off
some people don't understand its
benefits
some people are worried about the side
effects so i think as we go
and and try and provide information to
people who are not yet vaccinated
i feel like it's our job to understand
what their hesitancies are
and then to use information that we have
that they are interested in
to try and use that information so that
at the end of a discussion they will
want the vaccine
i've talked to a lot of medical experts
a lot of people i trust who say the the
profile for these vaccines is really
great as far as efficacy standpoint
however there are indications
of uh pockets of and whether that's
hundreds or thousands
of people who have problems there are
people who say they've linked it to
deaths
whether this number is very small are
those things being looked at by the cdc
is that investigation happening we don't
we don't
hear about it obviously absolutely we
are watching this incredibly carefully
through numerous different vaccine
safety systems this vaccine adverse
event system
we have a vsa system a passive reporting
system
we have what we call a vaccine safety
data link that is collaborating with
hospitals we are watching this
extraordinarily carefully
and what i would say is we have uh
vaccinated 164 million
americans so we have an extraordinary
amount of data
since december as we started getting
vaccinating people
and we've been able to find very very
rare signals when they've occurred
and so i have extraordinary confidence
in the safety of these vaccines
yeah which makes the question about the
fda and authorization
seem really important if it's about
shelf life it seems like it's a little
too long
i want to turn to schools there's a lot
of parents who send in questions
all across the country they're wondering
what it's going to look like for their
kids
and masks especially for young kids two
three four five
six here's josh
why is the cdc not looking at the
emotional impacts
and the other physical impacts that
having a mask on a child as young as
three or four
five six seven years old
nobody seems to be talking about the
emotional or physical impacts
that having a mask on a child for that
long is having and the cdc
should be looking at this why are they
not are you not
are you brett thank you for that
question josh thank you for that
question here's what i can tell you
first of all i have three kids myself
and i completely understand we want our
kids back in school and that is so very
important
over the summer we've had numerous
summer school outbreaks
that have occurred when masks are not
worn we've had
jurisdictions have had to close schools
because there are so many clusters
happening in the school system
so my primary goal is to get all our
kids back
in person safely for full-time learning
and to do so and to be able to keep the
schools open to prevent those clusters
from happening in school
right now the best way to do that is to
have everybody masked because we do have
disease in the community
and hopefully as we have vaccinations
for kids
and less disease in the community we'll
be able to
to scale back on the mask wearing but
those are cases right
those aren't hospitalizations and those
aren't deaths you have a percentage of
kids
young kids hospitalizations and deaths
um you know we are following that very
carefully
what i will say is that um certainly
the kids do better than adults do um the
older people the
the more hospitalizations have occurred
in demographics that are over the age of
65.
but we are seeing illness in some kids
who get
um who get coveted and it's illness at
the rates or even higher than the rates
of influenza
so in my mind as a vaccine preventable
disease
we want to make sure that our kids stay
in school
wearing a mask and then when the
vaccines should the vaccines become
available for our children
to vaccinate them to keep them safe and
healthy all right here's what the head
of the teachers union
said about opening schools in the fall
vaccination is the number one gold
standard
that we need to you know bring back our
mass for schools
we're going to keep kids safe we're
going to keep our members safe
and we're going to try to open up
schools
try to open up schools it sounds like a
maybe from randy warren weingarten the
nea
obviously is a union advocating for its
members and that's
important and it's important stakeholder
to the cdc obviously
setting guidelines for schools in the
fall but but who are the advocates for
the children
and the parents which teachers unions
have not been at least in in that
particular question
and as the cdc prepares recommendations
for in-person
learning especially for kids under 12 as
you heard josh talk about
what's the scientific basis for masking
young children you know i think that
we have to when we we have seen in
schools that when the children come into
schools with disease in the community
it can spread in schools if the children
are not masked
and so when we have high rates of
disease in the community
we are going to see some cases in the
school
but it's more kind of for the teachers
in the those schools
you know a lot of these kids first of
all there is some disease in kids these
kids go back to homes where they have
parents they have immunocompromised
parents they have
other children in the household so
really what we're trying to do is
prevent spread in the schools and
in the communities and so you know
generally what we're trying to do is get
our kids back in full per full time
in-person learning um and to decrease
the amount of disease
in the communities so that our children
can be back in school
last thing you know i hear from a lot of
people that say
you know there's one thing and then
another thing and we hear it about
vaccinations and mass but we also hear
it about
for example one woman wrote in my
in-laws live in austria
they cannot come here to see their
six-month-old baby because of the eu
travel ban
even as migrants come across the
southern border
from other countries with more covet and
worse vaccine performance and they're
allowed in
is that a problem dr wilski
we're working in at the cdc to provide
technical assistance for all areas of
travel
as well as to provide technical
assistance at the southern border so as
people come in we are keeping
migrants as well as those communities as
safe as possible with the technical
assistance
and infection prevention guidelines from
the cdc do you know the surge
how the surge of illegal immigrants with
covet is affecting the overall
rate you know it sounds like the
percentages down there on the border are
astronomical yeah you know i would say
that the
percentages in the southern part of this
country are really quite high um
and i don't necessarily think we can
attribute all of that to what's going on
at the southern border i think what we
really need to do
is spend our time getting our
communities vaccinated to getting our
individuals vaccinated to
prevent disease from transmitting in our
communities lighting around here which
vaccine is best against the delta
variant
i don't think we have data to suggest
that one vaccine is better than another
so i would say
um there are you know three vaccines
we're lucky to have three vaccines that
are available
and get the information that you need to
feel
comfortable rolling up your sleeves and
getting vaccinated yeah well you're
going to talk to your doctor about that
but if there's a mandate you're not
picking one over another as far as the
delta variant is what you're saying
but if you let's say you got the j and j
is it okay to get the pfizer
after that because you want to
right now we don't have uh full data
from
j or the fda to make an evaluation on
that assessment
which kind of leads to that question
about data and details
i mean it's been a long time and you
have a lot of
170 million people that or 64.
don't you guys have a lot of data as of
this point
so the fda is looking at the data from
the companies uh that are conducting
these analyses the cdc is not conducting
crossover studies as we call them
getting one vaccine and then getting a
boost from a second
so um the fda have access to those data
and as they make those decisions i am
certain those data will become should we
avoid big crowds at this point i mean
are we going to have an nfl season
an nhl season nba season
um i am really hopeful that we will
i you know what i think is really clear
is that
if we unify together as a country if we
take the steps that are necessary to
squash the amount of disease that is
there now
we can do so in a matter of weeks if we
all
get vaccinated if we may our masks until
then
there is so much that can be done in
such a short period of time to squash
this
um and i would really love to see um
kickoff season
last thing israel is already doing a
booster for people over 60
are we going to do that we are working
and looking at the data as i mentioned
we have numerous cohorts following tens
of thousands of people across the united
states we're looking at those data every
week every two weeks we're collaborating
with international
partners such as israel and the uk and
many others
to look at their those data and one
thing i will say is that
when the data demonstrate that we are
ready to give boosters
um the government will be ready we are
planning right now
dr wolinski we appreciate you giving us
an extended amount of time as you can
hear by all the questions around the
country there's
some confusion and a lot of concern but
we
hope that you can come back sometime and
continue to fill us
in i'd absolutely be happy to thanks for
having me